المشاهدينا نعود ونذكر بانه هذه الصور هذا
الفيديو هي للمسافه التي قطعها ترامب من
موكب الرئيس طبعا الامريكي دونالد ترامب
من برجه في وسط نيويورك الى قاعه المحكمه
في منهاتن كما اشتبعنا منذ قليل في هذا
السهم هو الذي يظهر موكب ترامب في المنطقه
الخلفيه لبرج ترامب وهو يستعد ليقل الرئيس
السابق الى قاعه المحكمه اذا هناك صور
هناك فيديوهات طبعا ارسلت لهذا الموكب
الذي نقل الرئيس السابق الى محكمه منهاتن
حيث من المرتقب ان يمثل امام القاضي خلال
دقائق معدودات
وطبعا الكل يعني كل العيون حقيقه وليس فقط
في الولايات المتحده شاخصه على هذا المبنى
مبنى المحكمه في منهاتن متابعه هذه
المحاكمه التي وصفت بالتاريخيه لانه لم
يسبق ان قد قد حكم رئيس للولايات المتحده
او حتى رئيس سابق انما كان هناك ايضا
البعض يعتبر بانه ليس الاول الذي يمثل
امام المحاكمه او يحاكم وانما عام 1872
ايضا كان هناك رئيس ايضا
تمت محاكمته ولكن لم يعلن عن ذلك الا بعد
سنوات عديده على كل حال نحن ما زلنا نتابع
هذا الفيديو
للموكب الذي نقل الرئيس ترامب الى قاعه
المحكمه